aquele lugar que não é verdade pelo
presídio anos elas a partir da minha
vida
foi ótimo ter o senhor e colou os
associados estão os lobos bandidos ou da
vizinhança que eu também já tinha ouvido
a mulher foi detida no presídio feminino
da capital do país durante 45 anos foi
parte da minha vida cotidiana do rio
muita surpresa entre os presídios nos
presídios
o real horário reservado que a polícia
recebe o nome de consciente no salto
eles mostravam o lugar desafiava o
título que a placa de chegada na unidade
socioeducativa de internação da capital
mais educação parece que ficava
escondido
a torre os muros lembrava será que no
presídio unidade socioeducativa de
internação
é o nome oficial da lei a onde estão as
meninas e os meninos em favores
não tenho um lugar adolescentes do que
imaginava sobre esse lugar artigo sério
é o que também mais acreditados eu sou
parte desse nós passamos a ter medo dos
meninos e meninas que alguns desses
atleta que não vou me levou para dentro
da unidade
tive de rafael na capital do país ali
deu rapidamente aprende que se não é
confuso tinha outro nome das meninas que
ele vive cadeirinha de novela e esse é o
nome que eu vou tomar com o menino pra
história que eu possa voltar à cadeia de
papel é uma certa para aquilo que não é
o projeto anda de cadeira verdadeira que
alguma coisa resistir a dizer que ali
habitam meninos e meninas não tira em
terceiro
alguns deles algumas delas podem ter um
clima de grave crise
vinte delas está além do tráfico ilegal
de drogas
o trabalho infantil e legal da cadeia de
papel da capital do país
o cartão de visitas num sobrado levanta
um pouco do jeito
esse lugar pelas mãos de uma escola onde
oferece ressocialização da educação é a
porta de entrada são três graves e três
trocas uma sequência de outras cotas
para cada um aquilo que se chama módulo
que uma unidade onde habitam e dormem as
meninas
o módulo
ele é composto de quatro
os 41 esteve na cadeia de papel
ele se chama quando entrei a primeira
vez eu não tiro o bloquinho anunciava
com uma nova visita à lusa
eu entrei logo e caminhei profundo do
corredor e no quarto de uma menina era
um dia muito quente
o som da abertura dos cadeados era
suficiente para fazer a apresentação do
meu lugar de visitar a mulher dentro
daquilo que eu voltei eu voltei já ir
entrando nos módulos e tentando me
apresenta a minha sombra havia uma
figura que se chama a agentes de
segurança
nós temos aqui de fora a cafeína
ela veste preto em uma tentativa de
começar a dizer que eu era professor
eu escrevo livros de dentro de uma cela
dentro de uma garrafa na boca de um
barraco eu ouvi um grito de escritório
eu quero que você me preparou uma versão
de uma hora com essa não seria eu que
fazia perguntas a elas mas elas a minha
parte
o livro que eu já tinha escrito e não
tentasse uma quarta dos últimos dez anos
e artigo o jornal
os temas são variados aliás sustentava
que há racismo no brasil
eu dizia que o amor é uma agradável
sensação de direitos humanos das
mulheres
eu dizia que as cotas nas universidades
em conjunto um leque amplo e variado
daquilo que nós chamamos direitos
humanos
o meu tempo na cadeia de papel é o tempo
de um dia cada vez nos termos daquele
lugar possui total uma vez por mês eu
faço o meu plantão das minhas colegas
regionais amigo nessas 24 horas
nos outros dias o meu tempo de
fechamento estendido repetência zelo de
uma contadora de história
no terceiro dia depois da distribuição
das pastas já da autoeuropa tinha as
meninas querem saber porque o aborto tem
que ser um direito porque o racismo e
moral
elas fizeram um filho ele esta foi a
primeira vez que eu entrei no corredor
do módulo já na companhia
eu posso jurar vocês que da mesma
cultura da mesma célula mas uma das
regras da cadeia de papel e que não
importa o que seja perguntado jamais
aguentar
eu ouvi a mesma voz que disse eu quero
que você está lendo neste momento
nesse momento um dia dramático
diversidade é um livro de estatística
sobre o carro de moto mas já vimos o
coco é muito boa em outras mulheres que
também é diretor
uma outra mulher muito distante da
cadeia de papel
nós víamos as mulheres pelo mundo que
escreveram que usar a imaginação para
contar suas próprias histórias histórias
outras meninas
eu transformei corredor falante como
esse disse
durante três décadas a busca de uma
busca de um marido
essa mulher se estabelecerá ela tinha um
programa de rádio
a história verdadeira história de
mulheres estão acima na rua meninas
aquele móvel no terceiro dia depois da
distribuição dos livros eu não tinha
mais as cartas elas falavam pressionar
ela me perguntava o que eu tiver e de
tirano e saiu estava o meia correcta
miller explicar o que é o compromisso
mais sair do local local entre o
encontro de um professor ea sua musa
nós vamos à moçambique lugar que não dá
é desconhecido há muitas delas o mundo
real a cadeia de papel também ela pela
borda não ser perfeito eu estou falando
na sua maioria tretas espadas da
periferia envolvidas no crime do tráfico
de drogas
para muitas delas não dizer ó 5 disseram
assim as filas 14 em que a escola willy
é o de menos tensão tremenda
há duas formas de pressionar que são
típicas da cadeia cnn tem nome não
poupou a poesia que pode ser repente o
que pode ter formas de expressão dos
sentimentos
uma delas me chamou de louco de dizer eu
tenho poesia uma coisa que está na minha
vida
isso é como se não tivesse existido
eu fico a me perguntar se eu não tivesse
nascido
será que seria a mesma coisa a minha
vontade de vencer não entrou aos 13 anos
no mesmo dia que foi mãe que foi óbvia é
definitivo e que era de suas portas da
cadeia de papel uma longa permanência
não não seria o jogo mas eu preciso
saber o que ele escreveu eu não sei
ainda o que vou fazer com as histórias
por conta dos poemas escuta os carros
que lei elas centenas no meio a entrar
todo o mundo real bateu à porta da
cadeia de papel e sem impedir certas
estradas era tarde
em congresso nacional do brasil resolveu
enfrentar um tela que considera que vai
fazer distinta e mais justiça do que as
estradas
a redução da maioridade penal a redução
dos 18 anos para 16
esse foi um dia
este a cadeia de papel eu escrevi um
artigo que agora tirar o espaço do
antigo deputado cujo título era qual é
um problema
essa foi uma tarde de 30 de rapel
alguns meninos na primeira vez em que um
jornal foi tocado foi objeto de leitura
aí foram querer que a constituição o que
é uma lei que diz como aprender como
cuidar como educar o adolescente estava
em meio à tristeza de descobrir se que
além da pena as trancas e do cadeado ia
mais precisava descobrir formas de
encontro e eu falo escuta sobre aquilo
que imaginar que a proteção na
literatura e no meio desse encontro a
minha realidade
depois de uma longa permanência na casa
de noel
na primeira noite sem as trancas assim
as graves escreveu uma carta a quem
responsabilizou pelos meus atos as
conquistas
aprendi no temperamento e que a gol que
eu a sinto para aprender a viver da
literatura libertou muito antes do
tecido de saúde e nada arroz trás dos
meus olhos
colocou em eterno se eu posso dizer a
vocês hoje
aqui eu aqui demografia ampliado mas
muito milton início de tudo esta tarde
nos desafiando a dizer a ela a menina a
vida como a vida é uma alternativa real
e nós estamos aqui para dizer
seja bem vinda